[Music]
hello, how are you, cristian
cásseres, with your news briefing from
news now in spanish? the demand for
the hobbit 19 vaccine is going down
here in the valley in response to that
the southern nevada health district is
closing some sites  i heard this on
may 5 it will be the turn of carmen
sánchez if you received your first dose
inside this place and you have scheduled
the second after its closing you can
go to the convention center and just by
chance that they are looking for staff
for more than 100 positions  this
summer
this hotel will offer a
2 day job fair to hire lifeguards
operators and servers for the
pool area you can apply today and
tomorrow and if you get hired you must pass a
drug test and
background check the laws  because they are also
hiring staff their
job fair will be on saturday from 11 in the
morning until 3 in the afternoon they
need vendors for
operating equipment  I feel customer service ambassadors
among others
you can fill out the online application
prior to presenting yourself for the interview
but for more details visit our
news
dotcom page in Spanish and finally we pass
with the weather forecast we will have
a sunny and clear sky with
temperatures reaching 70 degrees
for today some winds will return to the
north of the valley for Saturday and also
for Sunday the temperatures will
remain at 70 degrees for the
weekend however for the other
week we will have
higher temperatures I am Cristian Cásseres with his
brief information from ignis denied  in
spanish happy day
[Music]